[Música]
[Aplausos]
el chico que vieron en la pantalla es mi
gemelo
yo no tengo barba en realidad
bueno antes de iniciar yo sé que a lo
mejor ustedes vienen
a darse
a contar a querer escuchar una historia
de
hablada por mí quizás como unas
excelentes palabras pero quiero decirles
que mi manera de expresión no
principalmente son las palabras no
quiere decir que me cueste hablar pero
me trans transmito mejor mis ideas y mis
insights dentro de mis ilustraciones así
que espero que las disfruten
no soy un buen orador sin embargo a
través de mis ilustraciones trato de
expresar lo que quiero y aunque ustedes
no lo crean quiero que se ponga un
momento
en el plano de un ilustrador que es lo
que hace un ilustrador antes de
y empezar a crear nos sentamos
escogemos todos nuestros materiales
ordenamos a veces nuestra nuestra mesa y
tenemos una nuestros materiales
si bien en nuestro primer reto empezar a
crear empresas a crear desde cero sin
necesidad de google sin necesidad de una
imagen ahí es cuando viene una de las de
las primeras retos que tiene cada
persona
muchas veces la primera idea que sale no
es la que vale
para poder estar aquí he practicado
varias veces así como cuando dibujo y
vuelvo otra vez soy otra vez me he
escuchado para ver si es que es el tono
adecuado
y quiero decirles por qué
porque normalmente uno tiene miedo
cuando llegan esas oportunidades cuando
a veces tienes que afrontar cosas que
tienen una carga alta de responsabilidad
y quizás
cuando ves a esta imagen tú quieres
escuchar
guau después de walt disney este chico
su vida su vida ha cambiado sin embargo
sólo es la consecuencia de lo que he
vivido paso a paso en procesos de mi
vida
he tenido miedo mucho miedo créanme que
cuando me llamaron me dijeron 'queremos
me contaron del proyecto
lo primero que tuve miedo es de caer en
una estafa
de que se burlaron de mis sentimientos
y yo creo que cada una de las personas
que están aquí en algún momento les ha
tocado afrontar eso
miedo a que a fracasar a que no das la
talla o no no eres lo que pensábamos no
es lo que imaginamos
y eso nos lleva
cada vez en una escalera
donde vamos bajando
y esta escalera muchas veces nos lleva a
imaginar que esta palabra que las cosas
son imposibles a veces creemos que no lo
podemos lograr o no podemos aceptar que
podemos alcanzar grandes cosas
ahí es cuando yo les digo
que se imaginen como empecé mi
presentación que se sientan y tienen ese
libro de páginas en blanco donde tienes
que empezar a diseñar las cosas a las
cuales tienes miedo y las cuales te
gustaría lograrlo
este es una reflexión que quiero
hacerles una introducción
personas como yo que nos afrontamos con
proyectos como estos o estamos estamos
muy ligados a la creatividad
pensamos que lo imposible siempre es
nuestra primera nuestra primera palabra
no que voy a llegar a ver mi trabajo
publicado en live leak sobre las redes
sociales en las grandes compañías y esa
es como que la tónica muchas veces de
nuestras vidas al menos de la mía si lo
cree y por en un momento y nos cuesta
imaginar lo que sí es posible
nos cuesta imaginar lo que nosotros si
podemos lograr hacer
porque porque decimos no yo soy realista
yo conozco mis deficiencias yo me falta
no he practicado lo suficiente como para
estar al nivel de los dioses de la
ilustración y pensamos que no podemos
llegar a esas a esas altas esferas como
lo han hecho nosotros
dejamos de creer en el amor
siempre vemos el lado negativo de
nuestra vida
incluso esta hoja en blanco que les
estoy hablando a la que nos enfrentamos
nos hace llegar a pensar de que no
podemos perdonar
nos toca volver al inicio
hoy quiero hacer una mecánica por así
hacerlo
si en algún momento usted puede cerrar
sus ojos y se puede imaginar como
persona viéndose usted mismo
puede graficar un blog como unas 50
páginas
ese es el libro de tu vida y tienes que
comenzar a llenarlo
a veces es difícil pensar como inicio o
en qué parte de mi vida estoy que puede
ser memorable esta página donde yo puedo
empezar a dibujar
pero no sabemos cómo hacerlo cuál es la
inspiración adecuada para llegar a hacer
eso que no puede volver a ser memorable
en el caso particular de esta historia
todos estamos en blanco listo
quisiera ser
una introducción para que vean cómo es
que logré saltar esos miedos cuando era
pequeño mi mamá siempre me motivaba y me
decía carlos tú puedes este tú puedes
dibujar hazlo hijito yo sé que te va a
ir bien para nuestras madres nuestros
dibujos son los mejores verdad
pero es muy diferente cuando nuestros
compañeros lo ven o lo ve otra persona
esa aceptación era la que muchas veces
yo buscaba pero
y quizás por algún momento un espacio de
tiempo
no escuchaba realmente las palabras a
las que debía de creer
ella me dio la oportunidad de entrar a
concursos y que ustedes creen que
pasaban yo siempre ganaba
es más
pero ganaba siempre los últimos puestos
porque nunca nunca logré llegar a los
primeros lugares y ese niño que está
llorando es en realidad soy yo
y ustedes saben que como padres o los
que son padres es muy difícil tratar la
frustración de un niño o afrontarla yo
creo que es algo que no quisieras vivir
porque
si está llorando le puedes dar algo y él
se va a calmar pero esto aquí es algo
que está dentro de él o sea no no lo
puesta al mar haciendo más es como una
voz que que quiere surgir y ha sido
callada porque alguien le dijo tú no
eres el merecedor de este premio
sin embargo ella
siempre creyó en mí y es por eso que le
agradezco mucho porque a través de su de
su fe es por así decirlo en mí me motivó
a creer en lo que yo también podía hacer
y ese fue el lápiz
esa herramienta especial
es el lápiz
que hoy lo he traído para que lo vean
este lápiz representa la fe la
imaginación la creatividad que cada día
me toca afrontar cuando tengo mi hoja en
blanco
como ustedes lo ven ya está usado un
poquito no quizás hay otras personas que
tengan sus lápices recién iniciando
porque nunca lo hagan
lohan no le han dado uso
y si lo ven tiene tiene marcas ahí de
batalla es decir que lo usó día a día
y esto me ha ayudado a afrontar como les
decía ese tipo de situaciones en donde
ya la creatividad a veces se termina oa
la verdad piensas que no puedes lograr
hacer algo grande
cuando era pequeño mis padres a lo mejor
no tenían el dinero para apoyarme cuando
quería comprar un juguete porque soy
coleccionista fanático sin embargo desde
pequeño me dio la posibilidad de
imaginar que yo también podía hacerlo y
jugaba con esos juguetes de papel
esa es creatividad soy de la época de
los 80 las tortugas ninja así que creo
que esa era de la televisión e hizo un
boom en muchas personas
incluso dibujaban los sueños de lo que
me hubiera gustado ser en un futuro
un superhéroe alguien que tenga la
habilidad de lograr hacer cosas en su
vida o en la vida de otros
para mí dibujar es imaginar
también cumplan
puede ser una carta de amor en tu caso
el retrato de un momento único
y todos tenemos esa responsabilidad de
afrontar ese cuaderno
empecé diciendo que no es fácil que la
vida se construye día a día
si tú cuando revises un cuaderno de
hojas
te vas a dar cuenta que cobra sentido
cuando ves página tras página lo que has
hecho
cuando vuelves a ese libro quizás un día
en la tarde después de desayunar y
revisas lo que ha transcrito con tus
manos vas a ver una una evolución página
por página así el proceso de nosotros
como persona no significa que ya tenemos
todo
hecho o lo tenemos todo resuelto el día
de mañana nadie sabe lo que puede pasar
pero tenemos esto la imaginación para
poder hacerlo en mi caso personal este
es mi mi imaginación en el tuyo puede
hacer la manera de expresarte en el tuyo
puede ser en la manera de hacer negocios
en el puede ser en la forma en la que tú
eres como tú eres con tus hijos escribes
una historia con ellos día tras día le
das ese aliento para que ellos tengan
esa esperanza porque estamos resueltos
de eso
en este caso
mi responsabilidad con él
con mi familia
con mis colegas
con mis alumnos
trato de transmitir en esas páginas todo
lo que lo mejor que puedo darles y es la
responsabilidad de todos no dejar esa
página en blanco
muchas gracias